ثلاثه رؤساء من دول الحوض الصومالي في
مقديشو هاجس المشترك يؤرقهم ومعهم الصومال
تجديد حركه الشباب التي ضلت شوكه في خاسره
الحكومات الصوماليه المتعاقبه على اجدد
المباحثات تهديدات الحركه وسبل مواجهتها
ووضع اليه لتعليم خطها والاهم بالنسبه الى
دول الجوار هو ضمان عدم انتقال مخاطر
الحركه الى اراضيها
القمه بشكل عام هو الاشاده بالتقدم الذي
احرزه الصومال في محاربه الارهاب
وضروره احترام دول الجوار وحده الصومال
واستقلاله وسياده اراضيه كما اتفق
المشاركون في القمه على تقديم دعم كامل
ماديا ومعنويا للصومال وجيشه
تشارك كل من جيبوتي واثيوبيا وكينيا باكثر
من ثمانيه الاف جندي ضمن بعثه الاتحاد
الافريقي العامله في الصومال ويرى مراقبون
ان التزام هذه الدول بانخراط اكبر في
العمليات الجاريه ضد حركه الشباب ياتي
لتحقيق اهداف مشتركه
من الامم المتحده ما ينعكس سلبا على تسريح
قوته انخراط قوته دول الجوار باعدادها
العسكريه الكامل سيرجح الكفه لصالح
الحكومه ويسد نقصها في المقابل هذه الدول
تتوجه من انتقال تهديدات الحركه الى
اراضيها لذلك تسعى لمحاربه الحركه
وانهائها او اضعاف تاثيراتها الامنيه
القمه الرباعيه قد تكون مكسبا للحكومه
الصوماليه بالمعنى السياسي الا ان نجاحها
يظل رهنا بترجمه مقرراتها الى افعال
ملموسه في ميدان المواجهه بين تلك الدول
مجتمعه وحركه الشباب
اكثر من جبهه تشتعل داخل الصومال بين
الحكومه وحركه الشباب ونجحت الحكومه في
استرداد مناطق واسعه في الاقاليم الوسطى
الصوماليه غير ان قله العتاد العسكريه
بسبب الحاضر السلاح المفرود على الصومال
يجعلها اضعف لمواجهه الحركه التي تعتمد
على حرب العصابات الامر الذي يجعل حاجه
الحكومه الى دعم دوليه اكثر الحاحا من اي
وقت مضى جامع نور الجزيره